democrats in virginia feeling very
uneasy with less than 24 hours to go
until polls open in the governor's race
there surveys show glenn younkin surging
against terry mcauliffe leaving the
democrats scrambling to change his
message mcauliffe now claiming the race
is not about donald trump after making
the former president a key piece of his
campaign
i call him donald trump and khakis
where's donald trump
he's pledged allegiance to him six times
why isn't he here
is trump scared to be this isn't about
trump this is about what's happening
here in virginia
and it's not about trump it's about
who's going to take virginia the next
level get us through this copic crisis
mcauliffe also trying to convince voters
he can be trusted on education despite
sending four of his five children to
private school
people trust me on education we have a
great school system in virginia dorothy
and i have raised our five children of
course parents are involved in it
jesse are comments like that going to
hurt him
yeah and it's not just about terry
hurting himself because he has
and that's why he's flip-flopping and
backtracking because even his internal
polls must show him losing the momentum
junkin is solid this is a tall
handsome guy with good hair
he's got a nice sleep here
he's got a good delivery and most
importantly he doesn't have a sloppy
mouth that the media can take as a
distraction and use against him but he's
also got this
he's got a nice vest
and this vest works for a number of
reasons this is a red fleece vest it's
now become who he is because he wears it
every single day it's red you know him
when you see it and that vest works in
virginia it doesn't work everywhere but
that vest in virginia that means you're
a professional but it also means you're
casual it means you're a family guy and
this guy has now shown that he can be
all of those things to all of these
people now also he's now seized on this
education issue which is so brilliant
because this is traditionally a democrat
issue and now he's united republicans
democrats and independents against terry
and the establishment and it also
softens his image because it makes him
look like a caretaker for young children
and also he's neutralized race because
he's saying i'm not for segregation
because this is what critical race
theory is it's psychological segregation
terry is for segregation i'm for
bringing back martin luther king's
vision of a colorblind society that's
what i want a colorblind society and
that is extremely effective
interesting uh katie about she didn't
mean that
because she goes
just interesting
gotcha katie about about the democrat on
the call of claiming this is not about
donald trump how can he say that when he
has invoked his name as we just played
the tape so many times to hurt his
opponent well he's realized that
virginia knows that donald trump is not
on the ballot and democrats for years
with the help of the media have used
trump as a way to scare people
into voting for them on a number of
issues but in virginia in particular
glenn younkin is not just running on
education which is something that terry
mcauliffe shot himself in the foot on
during that debate he's also running on
things that people care about like
eliminating the state grocery tax while
a grocery is going through the roof he's
been campaigning on wanting to repeal
the state gas tax temporarily so people
have more money in their pocket so while
terry mcauliffe has tried to nationalize
this race to make it all about trump and
broaden everybody under the sun glenn
younkins really made it about people in
virginia and i think it also he's made
it about everybody he's made it less
political whereas terry mcauliffe is a
political machine backed by the clintons
and that's why glenn yonkin is getting
support from people of all kinds of
backgrounds greg bill maher has this
warning for virginia democrats listen
terry mccall if he was the governor he's
running again he should walk away with
it he's neck and neck because he's
the issue became schools i said this
months and months ago that the issue in
the coming elections is going to be
what's going on in the schools
why parents vote
and they don't like what's going on in
school they feel like they are losing
control
good point it's actually a great point
i'm glad he watches my show
we got we cannot forget like one of the
biggest stories in virginia was the the
unstable scum buckets of project lincoln
project who tried to exploit racial
conflict by creating a hoax right
and
that is to this point in the fact that
race has become the prism that the media
and the democrats often decide to see
everything through and not even the
concern for your children there are
there are columnists and people in the
media who claim that uh when people say
you're a concerned parent they really
mean concerned white parent so now
parenting is being seen through this
race racial prism by people like
mccullough who sends their kids to
private schools because if you went by
their logic then if you sent your kids
to private schools you are a concerned
parent
ergo
white parent i don't know what ergo
means
but i think this this hope this hoax
thing might be that turning point where
the dems have to consider letting go of
this racial prism
you know uh we it's time to change the
tools and start and start like operating
on a different i don't know in a
different manner than they are now
harold
so
uh there's a lot there i think that when
you think about the education issue in
virginia there's no doubt uh you would
not have imagined three months ago that
republicans would have the advantage
around it now there are a number of
factors and a lot of them have been
raised here i think i'm a concerned
parent i have two kids and my kids
happen to be black and white and i i
care deeply about him and want the
schools to perform well i know i know
greg meant that as well
but in this race here
two things are going to be learned if
glenn younkin wins this is the playbook
for republicans next year to to win in
midterms individual candidates and it's
really a playbook for how do you
capitalize on the best of donald trump
and try to shun the parts that don't do
well i would remind everybody that
republicans probably would be in the
majority in the senate uh had donald
trump not divided republicans in georgia
two if terry wins
it's a message for democrats that the
moderate down the middle economic
message remember for the two of the last
four years virginia's been the number
one state to do business and according
to a rival business network's analysis
of this they're based on taxes education
livability uh terry was governor five
years ago so democrats have to
understand you've got to get back to
talking about the economy you got to get
back to talking about as james carville
says the economy stupid but
understanding where parents are and this
year it's education and if terry does
not win this race this will be probably
the biggest reason the biggest factor is
to why great preview of what we're going
to see play out tomorrow hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else